[Music]
heather how can we help
hey how are you we are living the dream
heather what's going on
i love it
um so i
got myself into a bit of a pickle uh
years ago i did a debt reduction program
oh cool it sounds like a great idea
you'll pay off part of my credit cards
not knowing they were going to kill my
credit and what was going to go on with
that
um
so i've been working with a program uh
to
deal with the credit creditors and all
of it and uh i'm just not sure where
where to go from here i'm like i
i guess i'll leave it at that
well uh
you being in a pickle heather there's a
way out of this and the the key is to
stop focusing on the credit score so let
me ask you this
why do you need your credit score to be
higher
i'd like to buy a house buy property and
i don't know i'm looking to um get
married and i don't know that if it will
influence uh anything in our
relationship moving forward hold on
you're saying your your future do you
have a you have a fiance a boyfriend
i do okay and you're saying hey this
guy's not going to marry me if i have a
low credit score
no i'm not saying that at all i i i want
to take personal responsibility for it
and i don't want anything related to
that to negatively implement them well
the best thing you can do for your
future for your marriage for buying this
house is to get rid of all the debt you
have and what happens when you do that
and i experienced this myself when i
first started working here at ramsey and
paid my debt off is that your credit
score doesn't go to zero it's impossible
well what happens is it becomes
indeterminable
it's a ten dollar word that means it
disappears you're basically invisible to
to the credit bureaus so how much debt
do you have
heather are you with us
that truth just shocked her into
oblivion oh we'll see if we can get her
back so heather will give her one more
shot heather heather heather
disappeared she went invisible ken look
at that i think i spoke it into
existence that would be really creepy
yeah or she fainted well i think the
idea that her credit score would
literally disappear into the ether i
think she fainted it was too much yeah
well if she's still listening let me let
me finish well yeah play this out
because okay let's say she does that
like you did so here's the thing people
go i gotta get my credit score up and
i'm gonna work with these programs and
debt reduction and most of these are
scams and uh like like heather found out
it just tanked her score it's not super
helpful and so what is helpful is taking
control of your own situation and
cleaning up the mess that's really the
only way to do it there's no magic wand
they can go here's an 800 credit score
overnight and so what i want you to do
heather is pay off all of this debt and
your credit score will soon be
indeterminable after a little while
and then you can do what's called manual
underwriting or a no score loan when it
comes to getting a house so what that is
is like the olden days ken uh not that
you're old enough to remember this but
back in the day they didn't have credit
scores to look at to give you a mortgage
so what they looked at was your actual
financial situation right and they went
wow you've got an income you've got a
steady job you pay your bills on time
your utility bills your rent whatever it
is and they go all right here's a
mortgage so on that front heather you're
going to be just fine and i can tell you
that because i went through this exact
process not having a credit all right so
here's the good news uh heather is back
with us we hope heather are you there
i'm here did you faint
um maybe i don't know
some technology somewhere was like
she can't hear the intro the demo is in
the wiring all right so george take over
so heather how much debt do you have
uh so
i feel like i can't even fully answer
that um where the debt was at when the
program started and then it went up i i
couldn't tell you what the total says
well that's a one we've got to figure
out how much money you owe if we're
gonna pay this thing off so i mean can
you give me a ballpark
i think the one might be uh nine grand
and the other might be at like 3 500 so
total of that is say let's eyeball it
and say 13. yeah okay and how much
what's your income
um
my income is about 45 a year
okay
and uh here's what i want you to do i
don't know how soon you're going to get
married but i want you to start cleaning
up this debt on your own
no more programs stop looking for a
solution outside of yourself you are the
solution and that's some really really
good news and like i was saying to ken
earlier when we lost you there once you
start paying off your debt your credit
score is going to become indeterminable
meaning you're invisible to the credit
bureaus and i'm not worried about the
house because we we've got great
partners like churchill mortgage there's
a ton of mortgage companies out there
that will do this thing called manual
underwriting or a no score loan where
they just look at your real financial
picture and they go all right heather
has a real income she's got a steady job
she pays her bills on time we're gonna
give her this loan
and i want you to do it in the ramsey
parameters um of a 15-year fixed-rate
mortgage that is no more than 25 of your
take-home pay uh so once you do that you
have a healthy down payment and you know
you're probably married by then is is
something i imagine and so you're gonna
have what we call dual income which is a
beautiful thinking you've got some a bit
a lot of power double income no kids is
where we start making major major
problems huge heather here's the dna
here listen heather um
relative to the amount of money you make
and the debt you have you can get out of
this really really quick so
i appreciate the call but you don't need
to be worried about your credit score
you want to get out of debt and this is
going to set you on a great path for the
future that george just so beautifully
described so you got this kiddo i mean
my goodness this is just about getting
out of debt i mean 13 000 in debt for
somebody that's single making 40
thousand dollars you pick up a side job
and you get your budget and
hang on the line let's get her and
ramsay plus i love that let's give her a
free trial to ramsey plus kelly because
what you need to get control of your
money she's not even sure how much she
actually makes here's your first problem
so let's go look at the pay stub and go
here's my gross here's my net now i know
what i'm actually working with i can go
exactly into the budget ramsay plus is
going to get you started it's going to
set you free good stuff